we talked about the tiago alves fight
that george had and john barred up in
class yesterday
i believe but the point is we're talking
about wrestling and i think that that's
a fascinating fight
that um
there's an incredible display of
strategy of skill of heart
uh george could you maybe
talk about that by john maybe too what
lessons you gained from that fight
go ahead it was your fight not mine
well
maybe it also tell what happened in
terms of your injury i think they're
around oh yeah um
so i was fighting tiago alves and uh in
the third round i um
tear my adductor muscle
it happened when i was on the bottom and
he i think he pushed my knee down tried
to pass my guard and i heard a pop
i don't know what i think you were going
for an armbar
you were on his back you switched to
armbar and he cleared the leg by pushing
on your leg and you went in with the
pre-existing injury in a tour yes and
and it it it got worse and and i heard a
pop i don't know what it was but i know
it really hurts so i came back standing
up and
there's a
famous video one that goes on the
internet about when i go back in the
corner and i tell my coach i'm like i
don't know what it is i think i tore my
my my adductor muscle and
greg jackson is like i don't care hit
him with your groin
i was very worried because i wasn't
paying but i didn't know i did not know
what what i had
so i didn't know the gravity of it and
it it plays on your mind so but i had to
buy to bite down my mouthpiece and
finish the fight you know i knew i was
ahead on the on the scorecard and uh i
needed to finish finish strong so what
was your strategy there in terms of
strikes in terms of wrestling so he's
exceptionally difficult opponent to take
down yeah well at first i i i knew i
would had a good jab a good you know to
stay always
from the outside you know fight him from
the outside and use my footwork because
he was like a tank he was much bigger
and much
stronger than me
and uh
i didn't want never wanted to stay in
front of him so it was all the way out
or all the way in and when i was coming
all the way in it was with my uh
proactive or reactive take down where i
myself initiated the takedown by uh
using a distraction like a jab to make
it is
and goes up and then i go with a
single double leg
or uh to react like baiting him for him
to come hit me and then
while he's coming to hit me i go change
level and
that's the way i like to take my
opponent down you know some guys for
example like like cabbie for example he
is very good at
bringing his opponent to defense and use
chain wrestling to to take his opponent
down i find that for me for myself i
specialize more into
explosive takedown in the center of the
hectare gun because i found it more
economical for me
what did you see you were you're
commenting john about the wrestling
that was that was quite interesting i
mean also can you generally comment on
the fact that georgetown people who
don't i don't think you wrestled
i wrestle i started saying i was 19
years old but i wrestled some very good
russian guys so they took me underneath
their wing and
but
my ability to cover distance
come from karate does not come from
wrestling wrestling is how i finish once
i get the leg how i finish the take down
so the the timing and the movement and
the explosion required for the squad
yeah
i think an important distinction to make
here is um one which george
uh made throughout his career and i
believe george you were the greatest
innovator in mma history um with regards
to this
and this is uh
the creation of what george calls shoot
boxing which is the amalgamation of
striking technique in george's case
mostly karate because that was his
martial arts background
um into grappling and in particular
takedowns
uh
when most people say
so and so has better wrestling
in mixed martial arts
you have to be very careful what they
mean by this there are many highly
credentialed wrestlers
in the early days of mixed martial arts
who went in and truly struggled to hit a
takedown
now these are
very very good wrestlers who in a
wrestling match would easily put down
their opponent
but
in a striking situation where the ranges
are completely different and the setups
are entirely different the stances are
different even the
the overall conditions are different
you're no longer wearing shoes people
underestimate just what an impact it is
for a wrestler to take the shoes off you
lose like 20 of your forward drive the
minute you take off the shoes
all of these make massive differences
in whether or not you're going to be
able to even make contact with an
opponent for a takedown
as george pointed out the true value of
wrestling in mma is finishing the
takedown once you've established contact
but that's only about twenty percent of
the action of a of a mixed martial arts
takedown eighty percent of it is in
understanding range rhythm setup
opportunity etc etc
and
that's not part of wrestling at all you
even the overall conditions are
completely different in the sport of
wrestling you start at very close range
in a very bent over stance and you're
expected to wrestle for
an international size for three minutes
at a time
now suddenly you're completely upright
uh
and
you're not wearing shoes all the
conditions the the the rhythm and speed
of it is different the counters are
completely different
it's just an entirely different animal
and so george was an early recognizer of
this
and started to put the emphasis on
direct training for shoot boxing
in addition to wrestling so he practiced
with very good wrestlers in the montreal
wrestling club
just the sport of wrestling and that's
what made him very good at finishing
takedowns but it was in his shoot boxing
training
which he himself largely developed
remember george started at a time when
mma was pretty damn young
and um
he we were when when you entered the
sport of mixed martial arts george it
wasn't even allowed on tv
like it was completely banned it was in
his country it was physically banned
they had to fight on indian reservations
and this is way back in the wild west
days of mma
and so as a as a young developing
athlete he had to
more or less do this by himself if you
ever want to hear some incredible
stories talk about teenage george st
pierre
had a coach who used to make him
put on boxing gloves now he was 16 17
years old and just put him on a hardwood
floor against a professional boxer who
was in his
late 20s at the peak of his career and
he said george you're not allowed to
punch you just got to take him down
while he tries to knock you out
and there was a it was crazy darwinism
yeah he was like
it's like you're gonna you're gonna
adapt or you're gonna die
literally and he had that it could have
been very bad but it turns out to be
great he's admitted
but there's a sensor in which people
think oh you know what determines your
takedown ability in mma is your
wrestling skill
that
your wrestling skill will determine your
finishing ability on takedowns but
there's so much more to it than that
um whenever people say you know what
what are the broad
elements that determine the outcome of a
mixed martial arts fight
okay on the broadest possible level i
always give the same three things
the athlete who can dominate the pace
of the match
the athlete who can dominate the
direction of the match
and the athlete who can dominate the
setups will win the vast majority of
fights they're in those three things the
direction the pace and the setups you
dominate all three of those
you're going to win 90 of the matches
you're in
um george could always dominate the
direction of the fight because he could
stop the other guy taking him down
and he could impose his own takedowns at
any point in a match so whether it went
to ground or whether it stayed standing
was always up to him
george had the most sophisticated array
of setups into takedowns
that i've personally ever witnessed
the whole distinction between reactive
and proactive takedowns came very early
in george's career and he excelled in
both most people tend to favor one or
the other
most athletes have a very hard time
imposing
their setups on an opponent and as a
result they have to use
the cage as a crutch for their for their
setups where they just bully someone
towards the cage and then put them down
on the cage george is one of the very
few people who was equally good against
the cage or in the open and could do so
in both proactive and reactive
situations
um
and the scary thing is that as good as
all of you saw him look in the octagon
anyone who knows george
as a coach will tell you he was twice as
good as that
in the gym where he would often go
against people several weight divisions
above himself i could sit here all day i
won't name names but i always laugh when
people say oh this is the greatest
pound for pound guy of all time and i've
personally seen george
take that guy down and crush him in the
gym and i can't say anything because
it's rude to talk about that in public
because it's just training but i've seen
george go with people all the way up to
light heavyweight some of the greatest
names in the history of the sport put
them down
advanced position on the ground and
dominate them in training it's it's what
he did during that time i uh george i
gotta say i deeply admire many of the
things i saw you do not just in the
octagon but
in training as well is um
the the the impact that you had
on
uh
the
the degree to which
takedowns were used in the sport was
absolutely inspirational that's why one
of one of the reasons why i always say
you're one of the the only athlete i
ever met who taught me
more than than i taught you because you
opened my eyes to a whole new world of
of shoot boxing and how
i grew up in a time when uh you i was
laughing before when you talked about
sugar ray leonard i was a kid watching
that match and
i grew up in a time where there was
boxing and there was kickboxing and then
i came to america and i learned ground
plane and
this young man here was the innovator
when it came to the integration of the
two